marcel et sophie rêve depuis toujours de
voir céline dion un spectacle ils sont
tout excités quand il voit son spectacle
annoncé au centre bell
elle se précipite sur son ordinateur
pour acheter des billets la facture est
salée 512 $ pour deux billets marcel se
dit que pour céline dion
ça vaut mais une mauvaise surprise
attend marcel lorsqu'il reçoit son
compte de carte de crédit
le prix des billets étaient indiqués en
dollars américains les billets à 5 112
dollars nu reviennent donc à 707 dans
l'art canadien
c'est dur que s'est-il passé sur google
pour moment d'acheter si bien marcel a
tapé centre bell or sans qu'il s'en rend
compte
le moteur de recherche là plutôt orienté
vers le site d'un revendeur de billets
american aux pénuries
il n'a pas vu qu'il faisait son achat en
dollars american le fin mot de
l'histoire pour payer le bon pays
assurez vous d'être sur le bon site
et méfiez vous des trois lettres usd us
dallest